oggi finalmente dopo tanti giorni di
influenza sto molto meglio
grazie a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovi io sono felice oggi siamo
siamo stupiti che è un gioco non so
perché non lo vedo un gioco abbastanza
dei febbra ti questo quindi lo faccio a
prescindere octopus non indovinare
octopus con il primo tentativo ai sismi
o magari poi sapete una cosa io questa
cosa ho sempre pensato a sé come la
febbre mi aggiunge dei punti di
intelletto più del solito c'è veramente
quando io sono in fibra ti faccio le
cose meglio lion
e ancora una volta che cazzo cazzo
disegna un leone aspetta a esibire
bellissimo ragazzo no vabbè fermi questo
ve lo metto su twitter 6 il bot sono
sono poco istruito la febbre non mi ha
dato aiuto qua a una barca a vela
malanno aggiornato il gioco perché sono
tutte cose che ancora non c'erano
l'ultima volta fi non spetta ora aspetta
brava madonna che però che figo moon
forse perfetto e l'influenza ragazzi
pause l'ultima ragazzi ce la faccio a
far questo impossibile ha fatto sei mesi
su sei all'inizio quindi non era
l'ultima che sfiga esiste con il potere
come potevo fare per haga fermi questa
questa ve la do mandare subito primo
tentativo bellissimo leggendaria primo
tentativo 6 su 6 il parere comune mi
interessa sulla luna come l'hanno fatta
gli altri non è giusto per curiosità ma
certo
bellissima la mia di temi sono nella
migliore tra queste van gogh può
accompagnare solo il leone sembra un
mafioso francese è vero quanto è vero
ayman artis sicuramente sto cazzo di
delfino disegna meglio diverse persone
disegnato da un bambino delle elementari
ma vabbe hai mai visto e coi baffi zia
cosa c era in quella carne di jeff cosa
fiera e quella carne sono contento play
again
magari ci è andata bene clarinetto
viva l'ignoranza non mi ricordo come è
fatto un clarinetto cioè lungo è lungo e
bastano a noi manca iphone ci voleva
l'arcata finale sono indovinati giusto
mi sembrava cosa che cazzo è un flip
flop le infradito in inglese si dicono
flip flop vanessa marano che cazzo
c'entra devo fare delle lesioni ma in un
attimo anche bella france sono in
credito zia sono le infradito sono
infradito
sarà lei pure di tempo storte dei stop
si capiva dai paesi andò al placement e
[ __ ] ai siseco ha dei problemi ai si
è mai dei problemi ma illuminata prima a
esiste ma se vendo velata un secondo fa
ai sinistra con norme portati ora blu
veri 6 punti a set
ma se mi ha indovinato un secondo fa che
c'aveva l'arcata meta che problemi hai
alla vita 46 stupida leaf foglia
guardate che bella nove ragazzi
seriamente come ha fatto non indovina
vabbè dai basta non facciamo domande non
ha senso se ho sbagliato
ok bravo bello sembra un fallo con le
ruote però vabbè airplane anche questo
sembra da un tanto un fallo con le ali
perfetto nei sbagliate due che erano
delle puttanate flip flops ha indovinato
queste questa questa qui che cazzo è un
pene al contrario e non ha indovinato
queste che problemi hai avevo i piedi un
pò storti ok allora va bè ragazzi
riproviamoci solo per canoe solo per le
canne ci proviamo ok dopo mi richiedi
canoa ti faccio una canoa perfetta van
gogh jana e se non indovini canoa
tramazzo bouty disegno david bouty con
una tia no ok cipro posso provarci io
santo che brutta cosa sto perché se
stesso perfetto bout ai si dice non è il
play ma l'hai fatto far prima ero ben
quanto sono stupido
si sa i cantieri ceva non riesco a di
fare le cose che ho già fatto che mi ha
azzeccato non rifaccio uguali che
problemi cellphone pensa che non mi ha
indovinato aeroplano mai mi indovinato
l'ater occhiali da occhiali occhiali da
occhiali occhiali da occhiali signori
harry potter si doveva essere la
cicatrice ma non lo era mai 5 sono non
mi ha indovinato airplane che va bè qua
ci stava ma valutare o propri sono
usciti dall altra parte la aveva
indovinato prima perché non ha
indovinato adesso spiega mimmo
rifacciamo se tartaruga marina dai o una
volta che è propria questa difficile ma
se esce non è come se riesco vogliono
clausi storta si va dai si capisce e si
fa dai buoni tra si capisce che una
tartare mediaset
leggo andai news dragon unico le zampe
da gallina tra l'altro bellissimo che
flamingo aver appreso non ha fatti devi
dare drago l'uomo pero ci credo matches
lastex e merci accendini sice matches
impara l'inglese costoso di merda forse
sa mica mi riesce al mini di salita la
febbre dopo mela controllo poule a
piscina mi che non mi ricordavo cosa
volesse dire pool quasi perfetto mi
indovini queste non indovini fiammiferi
ti rendi conto di quanto sei
rincoglionita barca era allora il camion
jones kim è chiara e semplice fiammiferi
come i fatti non indovinare i fiammiferi
era semplicissimo guarda che caso ha
fatto gli altri dai ma che schifo fa dio
santo io porterei solo
solo ed esclusivamente queste due solo
queste ragazzi solo queste due ma come
si è fatto in dominare dragone no
tartaruga marina così come possibile lo
compro per 3.000 euro il drago
indemoniato bello è che era questo il
mio drago ma che sta partorendo
non lo so zia non lo so che stai
scherzando spero no a zio acesi amburgo
block clock tanto mi sono sdraiato che
si pensa mi colpisce bene è una donna e
due velocissimo baird e keith subito a
esistere vai a carico face telephone
ok questo avevo già fatto a cena
all'hotel e fondo non mi ricordo dai la
cornetta dai porti a [ __ ] un telefono
si vede [ __ ] scambiato per
cellulare guitar figlio di tua madre che
sfiga lercia cosa stavo facendo e di
sheeran perdonami per mi vida loca
boomerang bene zebra minchia la zebra
tra tutte le cose
ice blue per fare le cose che non so
come fare perché non la so fare e mio
con gli animali non mi fate fare gli
animali per l'amor di dio
[ __ ] mermaid silena sirena ho capito
adesso non mi ricordavo più partire dai
capelli ragazzi seguite i miei consigli
sul disegno che io annesso tantissimo a
strisce sono borsa
ai siti dei formati sai ai conti a 7
cos'era non ho visto ax o maria salvador
non è quello che cazzo fatto ai siti a
noi si può psico bene
meno male che l'ha indovinata mai
nominato queste non sirena pensate come
sta messo male pensa che problemi center
che non è un dente tedesco vero tenda
come mai portato bene
hp 4 d ora che non sono più riuscita a
fare sei su sei è impossibile gli occhi
cazzola fatto sì ovviamente questa è una
sirena sono tutte molto questa è una
vagina è una pagina flamingo o l'amico
interiore riusciti
mamma mia ragazzi mamma mia che stile
trattore baskera vasca da bagno maschera
bagno no la vasca da bagno in casa
ragazzi non so come è fatta la vasca da
bagno
non è che non mi lavo non ce l'ho
non mi lavo perché non c'è bocca cimice
è rivoltata prova best reply reali che
cazzo lampione misero semplice l'avevo
già fatto 666 che bel flamingo mamma mia
ragazzi dove flamingo merita il trattore
perfetto ma vasca da bagno riuscita bene
sembra una culla con le rotelle bocca e
bellissima effettivamente le altre hanno
un po meglio abbiamo che i commenti
della people vediamo che ne pensa uno
strano li abbia presi tutti
effettivamente il trattore fa ridere non
mi esprimo
gli hanno spezzato il collo il
fenicottero va bene è questo che è stato
lo so disegnare
è un cappello da elfo che cammina è vero
ragazzi miei basta mi è tornata la fede
non avevo più mi è tornata con questo
video
spero abbiate tutti imparato che cosa
significa essere un vero artista ma veri
spero che questo mi sia piaciuto
ragazzina con quello che vide cose i
ragazzi si vede piaciuto al momento non
mi piace anche i vari social che come
inviato dalla descrizione eserciti siate
ci vediamo al prossimo video di terra
ragazzi